[Music]  it was an emotional day in court as the  father of the man accused of killing  leslie palacio was sentenced 46-year-old  jose rankel will serve two years he  accepted a plea deal a few months back  pleading guilty to being an accessory to  murder for destroying evidence two years  is the maximum sentence several members  of the palacio family were present today  sharing how her death has impacted them  while they're happy he got the longest  sentence possible they tell us it's not  enough we do  feel like the system did  fail us in a way although we do know  like they can't do anything like than  give him like more than two years it's  still not really justice for us  tranquil has also been credited  days he's already served the palacio  family is now offering a ten thousand  dollar reward for information leading to  his son eric's arrest they plan to  create the leslie palacio law to help  bring harsher punishments to crimes like  the ones ranquel is facing